nice let's get started first of all the
emergency evacuation help and we do have
a motion we did the motor fact nation
should we've been required to fact about
building these leaves the building by
the nearest available exit there is one
Forex in the lives of just mentioned
if you meet with their communities do so
by the glass door to the external try
and same staircase please hold
both handrails and face the stairs of
wet and slippery
anyone is able to use the stairs would
you please allow the others to exit the
room before they may go too far a spent
door where they would be giving
assistance assembly point is the public
car park on the side of the city suite
please do not do they in your evacuation
to correctly got into please do not
return to building until given
permission to do so by council staff for
me please note this meeting will be
audio recorded and are please provide
you to switch remote off off your mobile
phones all tournaments like this
apologies for absence I have counselor
goody and councillor Ward
substitute business is ready others
substitute members counselor this
question is substituting for counselors
don't hesitate
Oh
we have copies of the minutes from
18,000 24th of April 2019
declarations of interest
a member of the
perhaps I should as the council
just forget it
yes
okay moving swiftly on to thank you
remembers the reporters in front of you
and just notice that it says Cherry
Orchard anyway moving swiftly on the
country properties it's a fabulous asset
that it's contained within the district
is that it's our privilege to maintain
it and the council has invested a
significant amount over the past years
to get it to where it is and the friends
group in particular teeth are to be
commended for they have taken the the
tiny annual budget and worked miracles
and leveraging in outside funding to to
supplement mountain and to its their
creativity in plant work which has been
so important to the country past being
the asset that it that it is but with
the new road and the car park in place
my suggestion is it is that the time is
right now to take the country quiet
forward to a new chapter and the report
asks for this committee to community a
member working group to put together a
strategy for its future financial
sustainability and the point to bringing
it now before summer recess is so that
we can identify members of that working
group and I can start but logistics in
place so that we can hit the ground
in September the the point very much for
me is around financial sustainability
and it's about making sure that income
that is generated through prudent and
appropriate and ethical use of the
country Park is reinvested back into the
country park for its for its future and
that the investment will protect it as a
legacy for generations to come
to say that this is a tremendous asset
fairness
questions
because when looking at the report says
just wondering what the many people with
the friends of junior medicine started
for about 70 is it stay the same
you know she's gone out but I believe we
started off with a group of four drivers
it did yes it's true five minutes but
it's quite it's very active we find them
quite news because goodness
[Music]
we could run
no preference
so I checked asking questions the makeup
of the working group did we look across
the whole of Kansas it's got 39 people
I'll be looking to spread it wider
ologist from this party well no because
part incomes of people that's with the
best experience I'm not I'm not
yeah I'm not putting myself with
something like a rivets but there might
be someone other than us
and whose item
and just right some company
but it doesn't bills I don't get
confused with trustees but I couldn't I
think it was bitter
I don't think the biting because it
cousin ideally I've been completed some
air and playful pleased with it it's my
own property prices it easier that done
very well leaving break my back so I'm
just
will there be members from the effect
it's intended that to be the case I
think it's important that remember
working group has enough people on it
that is that it is diverse but that he
doesn't have too many people and that it
becomes on
so to answer counselor Wilson's question
I think that there are opportunities for
people who have particular contributions
to make to be invited to give those
contributions essentially present to the
committee without necessarily making a
community members difficulty group
member result and certainly we wouldn't
dream of doing anything without the
friends who's being part of being the
conversation what sort of size worth the
drive
it's a matter before for the committee
chair ID leads and we're between four
and seven it's usually quite a nice
number to work because and it means that
inevitably no confusion time not
everybody can always attend immediately
you still have young people to have a
decent conversation
could you give us a price see of what
you expect the income and expenditure on
the proposals to be long-term I'm
talking about including events that you
are looking at that will be income
generating I'm guessing you considered
don't become my compliments yeah
so only provisionally I obviously
otherwise I would have put I don't want
to prejudge the work of the Working
Party but the the size of the country
part lends itself to a master plan
approach which identifies those parts of
the country prop which will remain true
to their environmental heritage and
remain essentially open woodland those
parts of the country part of which lend
themselves to permanent fixtures such as
play equipment high ropes or even cafe
or something like that and then there's
event space and event space into my mind
involves a longer but the program of
activity so it's not just a flash in the
pan that happens once a year that it's a
program of activities over a rolling
period with a number of kind of anchor
events which subsidize smaller community
events so that a paid concert for
example would subsidize free Jamboree
scouts for example so the rough
approximation of that I think it's got
to the the mental side of thing has got
to turn something like
so are you looking for the long-term
feature of this to be a negative speaker
yes at the moment at the moment that
council paid the castles budget is eight
and a half thousand pounds so there is
so the whole idea is to needs to start
from the beginning and create the the
business model for the country pop up on
a computer sustainable basis so that
immediately starts to generate income
which it invests back into the part when
you say immediately
well there are a number of I think that
comes down to where the working property
gets to the terms of reference indicate
a reporting date at the end of this
calendar year so I would anticipate that
depending on what the solution is that
comes up that the working body comes up
with that once that solution has been
procured or or whatever however long
that that takes that we would be looking
for income generation to be almost
immediate but to some extent that
doesn't it's not that's not the key
driver here because actually what we're
looking to do is not save costs we're
looking to secure its future so that's
why I think it's important to get it
right
reason being why I ask that is as you
know our county in varies
if I've been working on which are real a
stereo it was not like that our
connection for the three medium camps
but it was basically to bring back the
classical culture
in my workup of their the good
orchestras need at least two years
laters so even if we say for instance
tonight sitting us down would you not
have Cynthia three years yes so I mean I
think there needs to be that needs to be
understood but if you're going to have
any significant the actual period it is
so that's what I'm trying to get a feel
for what your expectation is on when we
get to the negative two and negative 8
because obviously we've got budget
issues in the next two years I don't
think so but but in any event what we're
eating so far as the countless exposure
is consent we're talking about eight and
half thousand pounds which is marginal
so yes so whilst it would be great to
save eight and a half thousand pounds in
in the next two years
it isn't fundamental to the ongoing
success of the MTA basically
doesn't happen but it's not necessarily
the financial impetus of making a saving
that's driving this it's actually the
longer term security and sustainability
of the country pot and the creation of a
venue and a destination which eat
genuine which enriches the experience of
residents and visitors yes yes I
absolutely there's there's no point
creating something that then turns
around and starts draining our resources
because we have to prop it up that's why
it needs to be set up correctly in the
first place
because it would open that subject
community they're using yes potentially
that's the solution that the working
quality look at which is that the
immense management side that we procure
a third quality to work with us as an
event to partner it could be that that
event partner sets up a social
enterprise to which we are you know a
certain social enterprise company which
to which we are also a shareholder and
owner or it might be that it's just done
under arms make the contract it could be
a charity for example that we that you
know takes the friends to the next level
any of these options are possible but in
in that's sort of that truism that form
follows function I think it's important
we understand what we want to do minute
first and their work out from there the
best way to achieve that and that's why
getting the strategy is so important if
you set the direction of the strategy we
then build the business plan on the
actor and the action plan that will
deliver that business plan we know we
were going in for the next five years or
so
thank you how receptive would the
Friends of Cherry which had been to
having all sorts of events going on in
the park because if I remember rightly
when they first fooled they were a very
militant balance that didn't like change
it's been discussed and so they'll think
the groups in it has evolved over time
I'm not speaking out so much from that
that's pretty why it's important to have
them on board in your discussions the
Sony question I get is in some they
understand that there's got to be other
attractions Indian such a generate
income
so if it's self-sustaining seen as we've
discussed there is income generating
ideas and with those of course we'll
follow over perhaps the need for a park
ranger just to ensure the quality that
song is such that it's maintained and
there are things they recognized as
being other benefits you know I know and
I've sat in desert either them for the
park we're talking about and possibly
even ten percent to the park there's
ninety percent there that we've done
research it's that honey pots of
approach you know it makes sense to do
so
we're going be they're quite keen to why
they're built to that for the experience
of your previous episode they think
they're quite keen to say how can we
make this part attractive to a wide
range of people having said that they're
very proud of the part we want to
separate that Park
I think the key things about some
aspects to ensure them whatever we do in
terms of investing in the park its
infrastructure that doesn't detract from
it its inherent if you like community
value Nadel if you don't care you know
the Tea Room but you know that this was
some careful thought in the design its
location etc if you're not you know and
you can stick informative cabin on there
by the park car park and you could be
making my night and saying you shouldn't
I'm saying this we could do you know and
I suspect on paper will stack up very
well however in a lobby so image of the
brand of that country park where you
want to take it to use may have actually
detract from its long-term value so it's
in some of things we need to think about
the pier fully I think you know this
dude needs a potential that the friends
really require kings and two techniques
the park is establishing and the
requirement in the years to come
to maintain the park is no increase
substantially all these young trees that
we put in ellipse and all rhetoric and
they are becoming fully grown trees they
need attention
you can't keep getting away with it on a
wing and a prayer we're a group in
Hollywood's we look after the woods
we're going to have the same issue their
Cherry Orchard any we need the funding
stream to do it and I fail some pounds a
year doesn't look good
sorry but if we get these sort ideas I
even just around this table and we're
not going to be the working group who
someone's calm down start what might be
an idea listen to you yes absolutely
Marcus and very very brilliant idea but
there are other ones
we publish others ages just say it'll
take at least three years to do that one
but there might be some that we weren't
good because I don't know and that's
what I think the member working party
needs to be relatively tight because the
output from that group is to write a
strategy but that doesn't mean that that
all members can't contribute their ideas
or come along and present ideas to their
working group because actually the more
information that we have and the more
consensus that we build the better
quality of product we will have at the
end to be the excited about this idea
here because once we are looking the
investment will doing something which
can return something to the council and
I think that that should be the modus
operandi of these for opinion tea so to
actually be working on something that
he's doing I think it's something that
is worthwhile making sure that everyone
is on board
it's it's a bit I don't that County
you're looking at all their powers in
the events of that
gruffalo trams
to all sorts of things at the various
parts of Sam's back
the county that they did so many things
it is city that we just made
somebody said have a hotel server and
develop into when they are looking for
it
so we could plan a map
is that bring blood
Kovalev three years ago they had an
athlete's festival which was very
wedding
I do everything again there's lots of
drivers out there I think
yes ma'am Thank You Toby oh just a point
of interest really what is the area that
we are talking about we talked about
Cherry Orchard but is that a hold of it
or what part of it or what's the size of
it we don't know what we're talking
about the park itself it's enough but I
want to know what we're talking about if
we're saying that there are parts of it
that we don't use in a part of it that
we are using what parts are using I
think that's the point of the master
planning process council Stanley that
the working party will take the plan and
I started to look at the evening of
what's already there and that might be
segmented into different uses
I think that's currently what's the
debate yeah well one is what masking
that is have we got copies of the plan
yes sorry I mean yes it's marked up as
to what can be usable copy
no no it lead them to the clock itself
it's in the map it's on page 12 of say
2011 documents have you marked up the
areas oh no because that's one of the
most planning process that there's
working party would be getting involved
activities yeah I mean that there are
different scopes for different
activities that's one and one of the
first things that we would be asking the
three to do is to do exactly that it's a
little bit the the plan as it currently
is and to look at its current use and
its potential use and to segment it uh
probably decided to do some work as
officers to to provide that jumping off
point for the conversation to begin but
it's it wouldn't be appropriate I think
to share it at this stage because he
isn't something that has been probably
discussed
okay sorry chair 428 can I just ask is
this is it your intention that the the
membership of that men with work group
should be considered now by this this
port or is that something you'd like to
delegate to I personally would suggest
the system traction
okay is everybody happy with the
recommendation yes
that